This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
The This program is for educational
purposes only. The content is not
intended to diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases, nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. Statements in this program
have not been evaluated by the FDA. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We're honored to
continue and share the teachings of the
founding father of science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics.
Hello and welcome everybody to another
powerful episode of Daily with Doc and
Becca. The show where we bring you
education, inspiration, and practical
tools to help you take charge of your
health and your future. I'm Becca Dukes
and it is my honor and privilege as a
certified holistic health coach and
certified naturopathic practitioner
to host today this show as we bring the
education to help you make those changes
in your life. And today is one of our
favorite days of the week and that is
pharmacist Fridays. That means that we
get to spend the show with our good
friend, pharmacist Ben Fuches, digging
into the science of how the body really
works and answering your health
questions live. So, if you've got
questions, make sure you get your hands
up. And if you're out on any of the
platforms as we broadcast across the
world on so many different platforms and
if there's a way to comment, you have
questions, we do have people that are
watching for those questions in the
comments, so they will bring them into
the show for you. If you'd like to join
us live, you can register at
zoom.dwithdoc.com.
register and we'll spearify that you're
not on the restricted list and let you
in the next time you visit
zoom.dailywithdoc.com.
So every week Ben helps us to connect
the dots between nutrition,
biochemistry, and realworld health
solutions.
Instead of just chasing symptoms,
we talk about how the body supports
itself at a foundational level, but it
can't do it without the right raw
ingredients. So whether your questions
are about digestion, inflammation, skin,
health, supplements, medication, energy,
hormones, or anything in between in
between, today is your chance to ask. So
this program is about empowering you
with knowledge. It is also a resource
for an amazing community. We want to
make sure that if you were referred to
this program by somebody specific that
you get back with that person as they
cared enough about you to share this
information with you. So get back with
them, let them know what you learned or
liked best about this program. And if
you have any questions, they are your
number one first point of contact. Now,
for those of you who did not get
referred to this program by somebody
specific, you can reach out to our call
team that we have at 855-9493377.
Again, that's 855-9493377
to be connected with one of our
certified holistic health coaches. If
you have a question and you'd like to
get an answer, questions
dailywithdoc.com.
questions dailywithdoc.com.
We'll either answer those questions here
on the air or email you directly with an
answer based on the philosophy and
teachings of both pharmacist Ben Fuches
and Dr. Joel Wallik, who is our fearless
leader in leading the way in
letting people know the truth and the
significance of the science of
epigenetics.
So, grab something to take notes with,
share the show with a friend, and get
ready for another pharmacist Fridays Q&A
with pharmacist Ben Fuches here on Daily
with Doc and Becca. pharmacist Ben
Fuches, thank you so much for joining us
today.
>> Well, thank you for today.
>> Thank Thank you for having me and what
an honor to be associated with Dr.
Wallik and all the all the wonderful
folks here at Youngevity, including
yourself and with Ellen and AJ and
Marilyn and Albert. Hi, Albert. I talked
to your friends. That was that was great
talking to uh to your friends uh the
other day. And um
>> I you want to answer answer questions?
You want to talk about that this
question you asked me uh on your text?
How do you what do you guys like to do?
>> So, we're going to do questions. We've
got a number of questions and that we
can get started with that one.
Absolutely.
>> I want Yeah, I want I want to address
that because AJ mentioned it before we
went on and I thought I'd talk about
this. So, here's the deal. Everything's
about the cell, right? We always talk
about the cell. Body's made up of cells
and then stuff that comes out of the
cells. The living part of the body is
the cells. The cells ha the cell has one
uh goal one role no matter what the cell
is and that's energy all about energy
the cell's primary job is to make energy
that's primary job yeah there you know
the intestinal cell does intestinal
things the muscle cell does muscle
things but it all comes from energy
disruptions in energy throw the entire
system offer
represents a disr disruption in energy
or actually it's a coping mechanism
following a disruption in energy cells
can't deal with they can't produce
energy correctly so they go into a a uh
emergency energy generation system
that's what cancer is so AJ and and the
question was about parasites you hear
about parasites
yes there's different things that can
cause the cell to have a disruption in
energy
for the most part it's metabolic but
there are other things. Radiation can do
it. Viruses can do it. There are
different things that can do it. So to
say, do parasites cause cancer? It's not
that they're causing cancer, it's that
they're causing a disruption in energy
and that can cause that can cause the
cell to become a cancer. So you don't
want to blame the parasite and the
strategy of killing things with meazol,
which is an anti- uh anti-worming
medicine, anti-helmentic they call it.
You know, it's craziness because you
don't just kill the cancer cell, you
kill everything. You kill other cells,
too. And that's why people suffer from
toxicities from chemotherapy because
yeah, killing the cancer cell, but
you're killing your stomach, your
intestinal cells, and your digestive
system cells, and your skin cells, and
all the other other fastmoving cells in
your body as well. So, we want to focus
on where our locus of control is. Our
locus of control is not on the parasite.
Our locus of control is on metabolism
because that's linked to food.
That's linked to what we're putting in
the system. That's why the the first two
points in the triangle of disease relate
to energy. Digestive system, blood sugar
system. We're overthinking this thing.
If you have, and by the way, we don't
like to blame ourselves.
We have a resistance to blaming
ourselves. And I certainly don't want to
be the guy blaming the patient. I don't
want to get, you know, that's not that's
not a a a a positive situation for a
therapist to blame the blame the
patient. So, you don't want to get into
that. But you got to accept we, if you
don't accept responsibility, you lose
your power. Then all of a sudden, it's a
worm parasite. I didn't do anything. It
was just a parasite. I was sitting here
minding my own business. I got a
parasite. Now I got cancer. Right? Never
mind what I does. Do do the people have
parasites that have cancer, are they
eating pristinely? Are they uh
supplementing regularly? Are they
sleeping regular? You know, doing all
the lifestyle things they're supposed to
do, sleeping and exercising, all the
other things. Probably not. So, is a
parasite involved? Maybe yes, maybe no.
But the point is we have locus of
control on many other levels. And that's
what we want to focus on. And that's why
what we talk about here every Friday and
Monday and when we talk when we do our
talks is so powerful because it gives us
our power back. You don't have power
over parasite. What are you going to do?
Put a parasite shield on? I mean, come
on. You don't have power over that. And
by the way, there are parasites and
parasitic infections are certainly a
thing. But the kind of parasites most
people talk about that are, you know, I
had a I had a u a colonic and all of a
sudden these parasites came out. That's
not the same thing. There's parasites
that are part of our microbiome. They're
naturally part of your body. Parasites
like hookworm and tapeworm and malaria
and that kind of thing, those are real
and they kill a lot of people. But when
you hear people say, "Oh, I did this
colonic and parasites came out." You
know, that's not that's a whole
different that's a whole different type
of parasitic infection. Focus on where
you can focus on your locus of control.
Your locus of control is on food and
nutrition primarily, but also lifestyle
lifestyle um um behaviors like sleep and
exercise and relaxation and breathing
and meditation. There are so many places
we can control the outcome of the health
of our bodies. That's what we want to
focus on and that's why I love talking
about nutrition so much. So, mabindazol
and uh and by the way these these
anti-warming me medications um they have
anti-e particularly ivormectin
ivormectin uh is an anti-cytoine
medication. It it's it um suppresses and
inhibits cytoines. Cytoines are
inflammatory chemicals. And so that's
why they used ibekin for the virus that
came out. And when people made fun of it
as a sheep deworming medicine, that's
true. It was a sheep deworming medicine.
But what they missed is that other
effects too that were beneficial, other
beneficial health effects. So when you
had the talking heads on the news making
fun of people about iberin, they didn't
know what they were talking about
because yes, it is a sheep dewormer.
It's also a human dewormer, but it also
has anti-inflammatory effects and
anti-cytoine effects.
there. Can't hear you. Is that me?
>> No, it was me. I was muted. So, it it is
good stuff.
>> Yes. Well, what is good stuff? What do
you mean?
>> I would say it's good stuff. It's a
drug, but you know, it it has some it
can have some benefits for for
inflammation, for inflammatory
inflammatory issues.
>> And it's not it's nowhere near as as
problematic as what they were telling
people to inject themselves with.
Got it. Got it. Okay. Um, well,
that is a great introduction. So, Wendy,
I hope that answered your question. And
let's go over to the next question here
on Daily with Doc and Becca. They keep
coming in. Let's The next one on the
list is coming from Barbara. So when a
vortex was created mixing a shake, how
long do the effects of that vortex
>> they Yeah, that's a good question. They
disperse pretty quickly. The effects of
the vortex will dis I don't know the
time exactly, but as soon as as soon as
the liquid stops vorticizing, the energy
is going to be dispersed. So you want to
drink it quickly. I I don't know the
exact minutes, you know, the exact
seconds, but it happens right away
because as you're creating the vortex,
that's where the uh ions and the water
is becoming struct the ions are
interacting with the water to structure
the water. That's where the electrical
energy takes place. As soon as you stop
the vortex, uh that structure will begin
to disperse whether it's seconds or 20
seconds, 30 seconds, I don't know the
exact time, but you want to drink it
quickly. That's true.
So if she puts it in the refrigerator
overnight, the vortex effect is longer
there, but she can respin it, right?
>> She can respin it. Yes. Yes, she can
respin.
>> Okay. And does it matter which way the
vortex goes, right or left?
>> No, it doesn't matter.
>> Perfect. All right. And let's go to the
first hand that is up. And Susan, go
ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Me then. Hi Becca. Can you hear me?
>> Hi, Susan.
>> Hi.
>> Good to see you all.
>> Nice to not see you, but nice to hear
you.
>> Yeah, I I guess you know I should do
videos. If if you saw my picture, I
would probably have you'd see this
little kitty on my lap. She's so cute.
So,
>> is it what is it? A human cutie or an
animal cutie?
>> An animal kitty. Yeah. I'm with my son
and his wife. They have they have three
dogs and a cat. So, there's quite a
managerie here.
>> Nice. What's going on? Well, um, one of
my friends,
>> you should be able to turn your camera
on, dear.
>> I try to. I don't I mean, I might do.
>> How do I do start? Okay, hold on. Start
video. Uh,
>> start video.
>> See here.
I should be able to video settings
maybe. I'm sorry. I I I never had
problems before.
>> There we are.
>> Do you see me?
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> Oh my word. Okay. What do I do here?
Did I select anything? Stop my video.
>> It went off again.
>> Again. Okay. Here we go.
>> Ask your question.
>> There you are.
>> I am. So, I'm at there. Um,
>> let me say something real quick. Let me
say something real quick. Um, Susan, I'm
sorry. Nice to see you, Susan. I've
known Susan for a long, long, long time.
Um,
back to the meendazol question. I didn't
mean to imply that the meendazol is
working for cancer because it's an
antiparasitic. Mindazol also has
cytotoxic effects, cell killing effects,
induces apoptosis and such. So, um, it
gets back to the idea of is killing
things the right strategy for cancer.
And I I would present that there's
better ways to deal with it, but I
didn't mean to imply that the cancer
that they're saying that it's parasitic,
the cancer is being caused by parasite.
So, I want to be clear about that. I'm
sorry to interrupt you, Susan. Go ahead.
>> No worries at all. Um well again um well
let me just tell you my I give you my
question. So one of my very dearest
friends um she's she's really dealing
with these recurring UTI.
>> Okay.
>> And um she's 65 so she's postmenopause.
She's 510 and she
>> Okay. I don't need to know how tall she
is. Is it just
>> Okay. Is it just is it just hang the UTI
or is there other things? Tell me the
other things. I don't need her body
shape or anything. Well, I mean, no,
really, that's it. I mean,
>> it's the UTI.
>> She She lost a son who died 29. And
>> am I losing Is it that me losing Susan
or is that everybody?
>> Everybody.
>> I'm I'm having a hard time hearing you,
Susan. Um, is it just me?
>> No. Well,
>> okay. So, go anyway. But Susan, UTI and
aside from, you know, the psychological
things, what what physiologic symptoms
does she have? So, I can get a little
picture going. Well, I mean, she she you
know, the urgency, the the bladder
pains.
>> No, no, no. Aside from the UTI, what
else is going on?
>> Um, well,
>> diabetes, obesity, smoking, muscle loss,
sleep problems, skin problems, bloating,
anything?
>> Well, after she lost her son. Can you
hear me now? Can you hear me? Okay.
>> It's just kind of choppy, but go ahead.
>> Um, she she's some high blood pressure
medication right now.
She she'd have so she's sort of
borderlineish. I think her A1C was 5.7.
Um
>> All right. Well, let's let's stop there,
okay? But I want to make a point for
you, Susan, for everybody. You see how
the patient will come with UTI, but
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening
in the body. Things don't just happen.
Like there's no UTI angel that sprinkles
UTI dust on your head. Oh, I got UTI.
It's an entire metabolic milu that is
dysfunctional. And that's how we want to
look at health. That's where the
triangle disease comes from. Now, I can
tell you go back to the triangle disease
and you'll improve things. But let me
talk about UTI because they are, as I
I'm sure most people know, especially
women, they're miserable. Can you
imagine having them all the time? They
call that interstial cyitis, by the way.
Was she diagnosed that way? It's it's
called interstatial
cyitis.
That's chronic UTI. And here's what's
missed with chronic UTI.
Chronic UTI follow
connective tissue deterioration at the
level of the bladder and the uh the
urinary tract. Nobody checks for this.
However, she's 65. She's got other
metabolic issues going on. Her after
menopause, your estrogen drops, your
connective tissue starts to deteriorate.
So, UTI need to be regarded as a
connective tissue problem. This is no uh
this should be no surprise to anybody
who's talking to who who listens to us
on uh on these calls that we do. The
body deteriorates generically and then
various symptoms show up guaranteed
100%. 100%. She's going to go to doctor
after doctor after doctor and they're
antibiotic and antibiotic and antibiot
because they don't know what to do
because AJ
the fruit not the root. I'm sorry. You
go to the root, not the fruit.
>> I was trying to get the song ready.
>> I know. I was giving you a heads up
there. They're focusing. We go to
doctors because that's what we're
conditioned to do. But they focus on the
on the fruit, the rotten apple, not the
root. The root of chronic UTI and
intestinal
intersticial cyitis. I'm sorry,
interstitial cyitis is deterioration of
the connective tissue, which is
systemic. She's got to have
osteoporosis.
She's got to have other things going on
with her. Wrinkles and fine lines as
well. She's got to have other things
because the connective tissue doesn't
just break down in one place. It breaks
down as a system. So, a couple things
you want to do. First of all, there's a
the way the female reproductive system,
the way the female physiology is set up,
it's a little weird how the bacteria can
are connected to the um to the urinary
tract. So, uh, gut bacteria, etc. are
connected to the urinary tract. So, you
have to work with digestion first of all
for a couple reasons. First of all,
that's where bacteria coming from. So,
you haven't mentioned it and she doesn't
know uh probably, but there's going to
be got to be digestive health issues
here. Now, the fact that she's got high
blood pressure also tells me there's
digestive health issues here. The
mechanism of high blood pressure is
stuff getting in the blood for the most
part. There's other mechanisms too, but
one of the mechanisms we'll say is stuff
getting in the blood. So, we got a leaky
gut issue. Okay. So, do you know this
lady? Is she a customer or is she a
friend or relative?
>> Different. Dear friend,
>> different. So, does she have a history
of digestive issues? Digestive. Bloss.
>> What's that? A gallbladder.
>> Bladder removed.
>> Okay. Am I psychic Ben or am I
pharmacist?
>> Of course she does. Of course she does.
Of course she does. That's called the
triangle. So you got to work on the tri.
If anybody had a gallbladder out, by the
way, that means you have almost by
definition some kind of digestive health
issue. So it's probably she's 65,
probably never been corrected. When they
take the gallbladder out, they don't
correct the digestive problem. They just
take the gallbladder out. So you got to
work on the digestive system. I would
get her on I26.
I would get her on the nightly essence.
I would get her on Ultimate Enzymes and
all the digestive support things. You
may want to have do have her do Dr. your
arases liver cleanse the true to-life
liver cleanse as well. So, first of all,
you're going to focus on this condition
as a digestive problem. I would also
throw in anything that can help build
connective tissue. Glucco gel caps,
um, healthy bone and, you know, I don't
know how much how much product you want
to put her on, but if you did, just
hypothetically speaking, there was no
limit to what kind of products you could
use, I would do the healthy bone healthy
bone and joint pack. By the way, the
healthy bone and joint pack will help
her with wrinkles and with arthritis and
with heart disease and with a whole
bunch of other things. So, it's always a
good idea to throw that in especially
particularly if you have a a connective
tissue issue like interstatial cyitis
is. Uh and then uh third of all the
blood sugar issues because once
glycation occurs it's very difficult to
address the deterioration of connective
tissue and other things uh as long as
her blood sugar is high. sugar glycation
that is reactions against collagen uh
sugar and collagen react that's called
glycation I'm sure you know about that
and that needs to be controlled as well
so digestive blood sugar connective
tissue building that's how I would
approach this and I guarantee you no
medical professional is going to tell
her any of those things
>> does it make sense do you see the logic
there okay
>> what about um you know the hormonal
stuff like they talk about as women go
>> let me tell you about the hormonal stuff
that's a good question Because when the
estrogen drops, connective tissue
deterioration occurs. But here's the
problem with hormones. Hormone replace I
imagine you're asking about hormone
replacement. Here's the problem with
hormone replacement.
Estrogen. When they talk about hormone
replacement, largely it's estrogen.
Sometimes it's testosterone, too. But
for women, it's going to be mostly
estrogen. There's no such thing as
estrogen. It's a family of molecules.
There's 20 plus different estrogens.
When they give you estrogen, they do
something they call bioididentical.
>> Okay? because they want you to think
it's the same thing as your butt. That
doesn't happen. You have 20 different
estrogens. At best, you're getting tri,
which is three estrogens, sometimes
bias, which is two, and sometimes just
one. There's no way they can give you an
bio identical estrogens. But it's even
worse than that. I'll tell you why.
Because
um estrogen is a very, very powerful
hormone. It's the most powerful of all
the steroid hormones. And your body
wants to eliminate it. So it gets
secreted and then gets eliminated.
Without a gallbladder, the gallbladder
is one of the main organs for the
process for the elimination of estrogen.
Without a gallbladder and intestinal
problem, she's already got a problem
with metabolizing and processing
estrogen. You're always making estrogen
as long as you have body. As long as you
have body fat, you're making estrogen.
So to now throw in exogenous estrogen,
pharmaceutical estrogen, which is not
even anywhere near remotely the same
proportions and ratios of your natural
estrogen, is playing with fire in my
opinion. Third of all, so you got you
got multiple problems here. Number one,
there's not just one estrogen. Number
two, she's already got a problem
processing estrogen. Now you're going to
throw in more estrogen, the most toxic
hormone in the body, and she can't clear
it out already. And then number three,
the way hormones work in the body is
they're responsive to the environment.
Your hormones are your bridge
between the environment you find
yourself in, whether it's the outside
environment or the inside environment of
the body and biochemistry. They have to
fluctuate. They got to go up and down
depending on what's happening in the
world and what's happening in your body.
When you take a drug estrogen, now
you're flooding the body with an
estrogen and you've lost that
responsiveness.
So to me, hormone replacement therapy is
just playing with fire. I especially
with estrogen, testosterone is is still
pretty bad, too. If you want to do
hormone replacement therapy, probably
the best the most benign hormone
replacement therapy is going to be
progesterone.
Progesterone
is not toxic like estrogen. And
progesterone actually
will sensitize your cells to your own
natural estrogen. So it balances out
estrogen and it sensitizes your cells to
estrogen. So it's a if you're going to
do hormone replacement therapy, that's
the one to do. Also to a certain extent,
DHEA, although you have to be a little
bit careful with the doses on it. And
that's probably if you want to do
hormone replacement therapy, I would do
DHEA or something called 7 keto DHEA and
progesterone. But I I'm not telling
anybody what to do because some women
like their hormone replacement therapy.
So I I hesitate to say no. But it's just
playing with fire. And by the way,
estrogen is on the FDA's known to cause
cancer list.
>> What about herbal, you know, like
women's hormone balancer or hormone FX
or zerapm? Any of those or those?
>> I'm sorry.
>> You know, they're not bad. They're not
bad, but they're not going to change her
estrogen status. They're not bad,
though. and and essential fatty acids,
by the way, ultimate EFAs for women who
want to um who want to take care of
their hormones and men for that matter,
too. The ultimate EFAs,
okay?
Okay. And then there are herbs also, but
they're not going to really change your
life either. Vitex, wild yam, licorice
root. Um these can have some female
hormone
hormones, but um they're not going to
really change your change your life.
progesterone. People use a cream. Is
that the better way to say?
>> I'm really sorry. I'm not hearing you
say that again.
>> Cream. The progesterone cream.
>> Topical progesterone is Yes. Topical
progesterone.
>> Yes. Yes. Progesterone is very well
handled by the skin.
>> Great.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you. And estrogen, by the way, is
a stress hormone. It turns it amplifies
the stress response. So, you want to be
a little bit you want to be really
respectful of estrogen. And if you are
taking estrogen, you want to work on how
you process it, which means the the uh
intestine and the and bile um and the
gallbladder and also liver health. And
if she already has liver issues with um
metabolic syndrome or or blood sugar
issues, that's going to be a problem for
her. I'm sorry to keep adding things on.
There's so much to talk about here, so I
apologize for that. But
>> thank you. I hope that helps.
Okay, good. Thank you. Yes, AJ.
>> AJ's raising his hand. You have to go to
the bathroom. What's up, AJ?
You can. You're excused. Go ahead.
>> Uh, no. There's There's more questions.
So, we're gonna go on to the next
question.
>> No. Okay. No. AJ wanted to say
something.
>> I'm teasing AJ. What's up, AJ? Give AJ
the floor here. What's
>> AJ?
>> Okay. No, because he was talking about
estrogen. Then he then he finally got to
the digestive part. And I just wanted to
mention that you know the hope product
you can get that they have a fabulous
probiotic that you can get separately
now and
>> better than the better than the nightly
essence.
>> I can't say better because I'm not an
expert but I know it's fantastic.
>> Is that Dr. Dennison's product?
>> No,
>> I don't know that one.
>> I think Michelle and Sanjieve had
something to do with it.
>> Oh, okay. You know, I think I do
remember that. I do remember that.
That's the It's a menopause product,
right?
>> Yes. But they but now they have the the
the probiotic is separate. They
separated all three.
>> I see. I have to take a look at that. I
have to I have to see that. Just to be
clear, the prob uh the um the bacteria
in the intestine, there's a complex
called the estrobolom. Estrobalome.
And they play a major role in estrogen
detoxification. When the estroblum or
the bacteria uh the intestinal bacteria
are thrown off disbiosis, estrogen
doesn't get cleared appropriately and
even worse it gets potentized.
It may it get it becomes something
called catakol estrogens and catacle
estrogens wreak havoc on the body. So
there's a major role for for um for uh
the intestine and the microbiome when it
comes to estrogen processing. Also
interestingly this I I know it gets a
little I hope it's not too confusing.
It's kind of interesting. When estrogen
drops, histamine can go up. And if you
already have a problem with leaky gut,
this can cause problems. And this is why
menopausal women will sometimes get
rosacea and um uh uh skin problems and
breakouts and such. Uh and this is also
one of the reasons why there are what
they call hormonal breakouts in younger
women when their estrogen drops. If you
have a combination of leaky gut, that is
food allergies and food toxicity and
digestive toxicity. When your estrogen
drops, that can cause problems with
skin, rosacea, headaches, night sweats.
A lot of menopausal symptoms are
secondary to histamine levels going up
when estrogen drops. So, that's another
thing that can happen to women during
menopause. And this is yet another
reason to patch up the leaky gut. And
really if you if this is confusing go
back to the triangle digestion blood
sugar and then you know the third point
but even just digestion and blood sugar
det the metabolic system and the
digestive system sorry
all right fantastic so yes it is called
women's probiotic complete it has 35
billion
CFUs and 16 strains of targeted
probiotic strains plus dietary fiber.
So, it also has the Lactobacillus
rutery which a lot of people are talking
about these days as well. Um, so I will
get that information over to you so you
can check it out and let us know if it
is as good or better than the nightly
essence. I personally love nightly
essence and take two of them every night
before bed. So, um, just one more
option, ladies, that we have available
to help us keep that good microbiome
going in our bodies. So, let's go on
over to Jill. Jill, go ahead and unmute
yourself.
Hello there. Thank you so much. Um,
I have a customer who
was told that she has elevated V6. Um,
she hasn't she's took Beyond Tangy
Tangerine original for a little while, a
couple weeks before they told her that
she had this severely elevated B6.
And uh so she stopped it because she was
seeing a nutritionist and nutritionist
told her that you know it's very
dangerous for her to take this because
her
>> she couldn't no she didn't say it's very
dangerous. I hope she didn't any
>> well she gave her a full piece of paper
that I can't even tell you how many
things are listed on it that she could
have that are causing this B6 problem
like from MS to E.coli the lie to I I
mean ju it was just like a unbelievable
thing that she was saying you know this
elevated B6 could be but she's not had
it tested before so she has no idea like
if she
>> very it's it's very unlikely you have to
you can take high B6 is associated with
neuropathies but you got to really
really go out of your way to take you
know 200 milligrams a day or something
of B6
>> it it does say right on the test because
she showed me the test it does say right
on the test that um supplementation
could affect the results of the
>> I I'm just you know I can't help what
this thing say. I'm just telling you B6
is an essential nutrient. It's water
soluble. You urinate it out. If you do
inject it or you take ridiculously high
doses of it, there are neuropathies and
skin sensitivities that are associated
with that. But I know I you're saying
you you had a whole list of things that
you said. Well, there's no way that she
took high doses of it cuz she only
purchased one canister and she has at
least a third of it less. So, she's
trying to find out, let's say she does
have chronically high B6. Is it going to
>> B6 is an essential nutrient?
>> That means your body doesn't make it.
That means the only way to get B6 is by
eating it or or ingesting it or
injecting, right? So if somebody has
high B6,
that means they're taking a lot of it
because you're not you're not making it.
It's coming in from somewhere. Do you
follow me?
>> I do.
>> So it's not like the body is
synthesizing B6 somehow. So if she's if
it's true that her B6 levels are high,
she must be taking it in somehow.
Correct?
>> Yes.
>> You follow me? So So um and I'm not
saying I don't know what she's taking.
Maybe she is taking a whole bunch of B6.
I don't know. But you got to take a you
got to go out of your way to do it. Not
only that B6 is B you're urinating out
B6.
>> Yeah. And that's what that's what she
thought. That's what her her uh
>> I'd have to that doesn't make it. Yeah.
>> She has I have it here. It says normal
range is 2.1 to 21.7 and she's at a
58.6.
>> So then you must be t it must be coming
in somehow.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. I mean it does it's not it's not
magic. It has to be coming in. Right. Am
I PTT is water soluble. It's not causing
the problem.
>> Exactly. Yes. Exactly. So, if her B6
levels are high, it has to be coming in
somehow,
>> right? Because that's the only way you
get B6,
>> no, there's no link or association at
all with it with B12 and how they tell
you that you might have trouble
absorbing folate. Yeah.
>> I don't know what you mean by that, but
B12 is not folate. B12 is a different
thing. Now B12 is a little interesting
because B12 is the most potent of all
the vitamins and so you don't need very
much B12. If you look at the RDA of B12,
it's like very very tiny. However, um
because B12 is so potent, um so
powerful, the body has like a mechanism
for controlling how much B12 gets
through the digestive tract. It's called
there there's a protein a peptide that's
made in your stomach that's responsible
for the absorption of B12 and that gives
the body a sort of mechanism for
controlling how much B12 will actually
get in the blood. Now there's another
factor that is important to recognize
and that is um that B6 uh or B vitamins
in general and and vitamin all nutrients
really when they test them they test the
blood
but the vitamins aren't active in the
blood. Mhm.
>> They're active in the cell.
>> So just because the levels are high in
the blood doesn't necessarily mean that
her cells are getting the B12 or the the
the vitamins or whatever it is. You have
to do what's called an RBC test or some
kind of cellular test to see what's
actually getting in the cells. You
follow me?
>> Yes.
>> So just because something's in in the
blood doesn't necessarily mean that
she's actually getting the benefits of
the vitamin. Nonetheless, the question
is how is she getting how is her how is
her blood levels how are her blood
levels elevated? It has to be something
that she's taking in.
>> Right.
>> So, I don't know is she where is she
getting where is she getting her B6
from? Just the just the BTT.
>> Yes. To to my knowledge, yes.
>> Um
>> Yeah. And she wasn't even taking two
scoops. She was just doing, you know,
like a half a dose. So, I just I don't
you know, unless the test is effective.
Does she have any neurop does she have
any neuropathy issues?
>> That's the main neuropathy is the main c
the main toxicity associated with
elevated B12
>> B6.
>> I'm sorry. B6. I'm sorry.
>> Okay.
Very good. That's what I needed to know.
Thank you.
>> Okay. All right. And also sometimes
people have skin issues like u skin
sensitivities but mostly it's
neuropathy.
>> Okay. All right.
Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you so much, Jill, for
coming on with that great question. Now,
the next question is coming from Corey
out on
>> And also, I should ask I should also say
if she has some liver issues, that can
might that that can also cause elevated
B12.
>> How about B6?
>> I'm sorry, B6.
>> Okay,
>> B6. That can also cause elevated B6,
liver issues.
All right. So, Corey wants to know, "Can
I put ultimate colloidal silver in my
eyes to stop the itching due to
environmental spring allergies or is
diluting apple cider vinegar better?"
>> No.
>> No, Becca. No, we cannot answer that
question and stay on YouTube.
>> Oh, colloidal silver. Okay. AJ AJ got
Don't make AJ mad. Don't make AJ mad.
So, listen. Look, I won't even say I
won't say that. But here's the thing.
What is the what is the mechanism of
action of CS?
It kills things. It's kills things,
right?
>> So why would killing things cause uh
help a seasonal allergy?
>> Wouldn't
>> it wouldn't right. So what is a seasonal
allergy caused by what molecule?
>> Histamine.
>> Correct. That's why you take
antihistamines. Right. So somebody has
anytime you have a histamine response
like um spring allergies and such what I
aside from taking like benadryil or
something which is antihistamine what
I'd be doing is I'd be looking for
endogenous histamine. Histamine is
produced in the body. So when your
histamine levels rise you're going to be
more susceptible to triggers from the
outside,
right? You're going to be more sensitive
to triggers from the outside. But
histamine levels go up from the blood or
also from food. There are there are high
histamine foods and some of the
so-called good foods. Remember we talked
to that those two gals um Kier and and
AJ's friends. I forgot their names, but
the one gal was eating a lot of
avocados. Avocados are are histamine
trigger or high histamine foods. So
there are ways that you can get
histamine level that you can have high
histamine levels either through your own
mass cells from the intestine from from
uh leaky gut or from foods that trigger
histamine release or foods that contain
histamine even good foods that will make
you more sensitive to spring allergies.
And this again gets back to the locus of
control thing that we talked about, how
you don't have control over the
allergens, over the pollen, but you can
have control over your histamine you're
putting in your body or the histamine
that's coming into your blood through
your mass cells. So locus of control,
you know, uh somebody's saying that
strawberries and pineapple give
histamine rect. Yes, pineapple is
notorious for that. Citrus, too. You
know, sometimes people say they're
allergic to citrus.
You can't be allergic to citrus, but you
can have a histamine response to citrus.
Likewise, seafood can be shellfish can
be a a histamine trigger. So, there are
foods that are considered good foods
that aren't on the bad food list that
people will say, "Oh, I just eat good
foods. Bad food I I just, you know, I
stay away from the bad foods and I only
eat the good foods." You can still have
a histamine problem. And you don't
control the pollen, but you can control
your histamine. Leftovers, too. By the
way, cheese. And I know I've said this
before, but I love saying this. Wine and
cheese and chocolate ladies, they're
high h they're high histamine triggers
and histamine uh will cause a lot of the
symptoms of menopause. Night flash night
sweats, hot flashes, anxiety. These are
all these can all be histamine
responses.
And I know nobody wants to stop the wine
and cheese and chocolate, but I just get
a kick out.
>> So I I feel very blessed that I don't
have high hot flashes and all of those
things that you listed because I love
cheese. I love chocolate. Dark
chocolate.
>> Yeah. And wine.
>> And I can let the wine go. I don't drink
wine.
>> But yeah. So definitely if you're having
issues with those things and you are
keeping a food diary,
>> food diary,
>> mark your actions after taking anything
or inhaling.
>> That's why a food diary is so important.
You know, that's because people are
shocked when they find things when they
do the food diary and all of a sudden
they make the connection. It's It's
really quite amazing what you find out.
>> Yes, it is. Yes, it is. All right. Well,
we've got several questions. Let's go
over to Phyllis.
>> Hello, pharmacist Ben.
>> Hello, Phyllis. What's up? How does
Phyllis always look exactly the same?
Every as the years go by, nothing
changes. We all change.
>> I love it. I love it.
>> You look exactly the same since 1997 or
'98.
>> Frozen in time. You're frozen in time.
>> We um have several questions here.
>> Um Olga on YouTube.
>> Hi Olga.
>> She wants to know what you recommend for
someone undergoing removal of mercury
fillings using a biological dentist.
>> Yeah. Uh you got to be careful with that
because when you remove the the mercury
fillings, sometimes mercury can get in
the blood. Uh lots of things. Ultimate
Selenium,
uh, fu fucoid Z, uh, NAC, vitamin C, uh,
MSM, Ultimate MSM. These are all
keelating agents that will tie up
mercury and help you eliminate it. And
that's the strategy for anything to do
with mercury or even just general
mercury poisoning, like if you're eating
a lot of seafood or something like that,
chilate the mercury away. And those are
keating a if you want to go all out, you
can actually go to a an alternative
practitioner. They can inject chelating
agents in you. But um there's lots of
supplements that have keelating
properties.
>> Would that be good for heavy metals in
general?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Heavy metals in general.
Absolutely. And lots of just blood
toxicity. Ke chelation is um not only is
it important for heavy metals, it's also
important for longevity. And if you have
unlimited funds and you're really
serious about living a long life and
you're wealthy, you're getting
keelating, you're getting uh uh ED EDTA
chilation or some kind of keelation on a
regular basis. It's a wonderful therapy
even though the medical professional
medical professionals don't really
recognize it.
>> That's intravenous, right, Ben?
>> I they that's what they do. They put EDT
ed EDTA in your veins, but you could
take oral EDTA or you can take
nutritional supplements and do it.
>> Okay. And Justin has a couple of
questions. What do nitrates and nitrites
do to the body?
>> Nitrates fuel um bacteria. They change
the bacterial millu. They nitrogen is
very very powerful stuff as any farmer
knows. That's why they have n that's why
they have fertilizer. In fact, one of
the great Dr. Wall talks about this a
lot. One of the greatest inventions ever
was um fertilizer because until
fertilizer, you'd have to use comp
compost as a source of nitrogen.
Nitrogen makes things grow. Nitrogen is
the difference between nail polish
remover and dynamite. Nitrogen is the
difference between glycerin and
nitroglycerin.
Nitrogen is explosive powerful stuff.
Our air is filled with nitrogen, but we
can't use it. 78% of the air is
nitrogen, but we can't use it. And
plants can't use it. However, there are
bacteria that can use the nitrogen. They
call nitrogen fixing bacteria. You may
have heard that term. And they in turn
will feed the the plants. So nitrates
and nitrites, they feed bacteria. They
change back the bacterial millu in the
intestine and they can throw off
intestinal health. Bacteria themselves
can start making gases and there's a lot
of problems associated with the
preservative nitrates nitrates. Um and
but the only way to really get high
concentrations of those things is by
eating lots of preserved meats. That's
the main way I should say. And that's
really where where um people get have
problems with these nitrates is nitrates
is where is with preserved hot you know
hot dogs, sausages, deli meats, those
kinds of things which are really really
bad foods.
>> What about using celery salt or
something like that as a preservative?
>> Yeah, that's that's completely
different. Celery salt's great. Okay.
>> But most of, you know, nitrates,
nitrates are really cheap.
>> And he also wants to know, does the
combination of methyl folate and
trimethyl glycine help with blood
pressure in general or is that only in
certain individuals?
>> Um I think he's talking about homocyine
probably. Uh and uh gly trimethly is a
methylating agent. And what was the
other thing you said? Folate. Folates.
These are
>> methylolate. Yeah.
>> Yeah. methylolate. These are methylating
agents that support um the processing of
the B vitamins to lower homocyine and
homocyine is associated with lots of
inflammation, lots of inflammatory
issues including high blood pressure but
all kinds of them arthritis and um
connective tissue deterioration and
accelerated aging. So yes,
trimethoglycine
and methylolate can both um lower
homocyine or support homo support B
vitamin processing to lower homoyine so
that um the secondary effects like high
blood pressure can can be reduced. I
wouldn't say they're anti-hypertensive
necessarily like blood blood pressure
lowering supplements but by lowering
homoyine they can have an
anti-hypertensive type effect. So an an
indirect beneficial effect
>> kind of but lowering homocyine is a good
anti-aging strategy and that's why
methylolate and trimethly and
methylating agents in general can have
can be beneficial for health.
>> All right thank you back to you Becca.
>> All right thank you Phil
>> by the way nitrates and for Justin
nitrates are not the same as nitrites.
nitrates
um nitrates are are convert into
nitrites
but nitrates are found in ve nit there's
nitrates they're found in vegetables and
such
nitrates are found in vegetables
nitrites are used as um preservatives
>> all right thank you so much for that
clarification on nitrites and nitrates
>> yes nitrates are actually very nitrates
are actually you know they're in leafy
green green leaf spinach, kale, that
kind of stuff. Um, beets, celery, that's
why celery seed works probably.
>> Okay,
>> nitrites are different. Okay, go ahead.
I'm sorry.
>> Let's go to Charles. Go ahead and unmute
yourself, Charles.
>> Hi. Can you hear me?
>> Hey.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Hi. Um, so I was discovered a few years
ago that I had very large kidney cysts.
In fact, one one was so large on my
right kidney that it obstructed a urer.
I got very sick and I had to have uh
surgery.
>> Not good. That's not
>> No, that wasn't good. But um they did
they did clear up the urer, but there's
still large cysts on my kidney. So my
question would be basically how do they
form without my even knowing it? And
secondly, how do I eliminate and reduce
them? Thank you.
>> Okay. You want kidney disease in general
and cysts um and cysts are um signs of
metabolic syndrome, signs of blood sugar
issues. Insulin makes things metabolic
syndrome is insulin resistance. That's
when you're making lots of insulin
because your cells are resistant. Um and
uh growth should always be uh first of
all attributed uh um
looked at as a cause of elevated
insulin. Now Charles I'm guessing is in
his 50s or 60s probably by the way he
sounds
>> yes
>> okay
>> 61 so it's almost impossible for you not
to have some degree of insulin
resistance the fact that you have kidney
cysts and there is something called PKD
or polycystic kidney disease which is
associate is did they did they diagnose
you with that
>> you know what my mother did however they
I got tested for the um
>> for the genetic
>> yeah they said I
>> forget genetic metabolic syndrome Yeah.
Yeah. Metabolic.
>> Yeah. They said I did not. But they
because of these they because I have
these large cysts. I questioned that
result.
>> No, no, no, no. If you have cyst, you
have cysts, you've got some blood sugar
issue. Listen, listen what the kidneys
do. The kidneys filter the blood, right?
And they filter the blood through very
very very very tiny vessels, high
microscopic vessels. So if the blood um
is sugary, if you have elevated blood
sugar
>> Yeah. or you have elevated insulin, it's
a short jump to kidney disease and
that's pretty much the main cause of
kidney disease and all kidney disease
issues or cysts in the kidneys,
polycystic kidney disease, etc. should
be backtracked to metabolic syndrome
always. And the good news is is once you
control metabolic syndrome, you'll add
years to your life and and you'll
improve your uh kidney health. Do you
what's your kidney function at? Do you
know?
>> It's actually quite good. The creatinin
levels have been good. So that's what
surprised me. That is well no no that's
not it can happen that way. So that's
good. And by the way your kidneys are so
effective that they can be down to you
can lose 70% of your kidney function and
still be okay.
>> Okay.
>> You right. So the kidneys are incredibly
incredibly resilient because they're so
important. That's why you have two of
them. So, um,
>> it's a degener kids don't have ju just
the idea that children don't have the
problem and and it usually happens after
age 50 or so
>> that tells you you're dealing with a
degenerative metabolic condition.
>> Okay. What do I do?
>> Healthy blood sugar pack. Reduce your
intake of fast burning sugars. G fast
glycanating sugar. Uh, high gly high
glycation
um high glycemic index. That's the word
I'm looking for. high glycemic index,
sugars, carbohydrates, you know,
processed foods, white bread, etc. Uh,
but also because of the triangle of
disease, it's usually, not always, but I
would
>> I would suspect there's probably some
digestive health issues going on there,
too, and you might want to look at that
because just the way the way these
things progress.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Do you have a do you notice anything
that way? Bloating, gas, dysfunction,
discomfort. Yes. IBS. Yes. And
>> oh, you have do you have a history of
IBS?
>> Well, mildly, but it's been under
control. I mean,
>> no, no, no. The reason I ask is the
reason I ask is first of all, you got
the triangle, AJ, right? The triangle.
You got IBS. But secondly, um there's an
association between estrogen and IBS and
estrogen will also make things grow. So,
uh I would I would be looking at your
IBS issues, nightly essence, um uh uh
I26,
um Dr. as far as liver cleanse, bile
issues, work on work on digestive health
in general.
>> Okay.
>> And and we have and AJ, I think we have
a whole digestive pack at root, not
fruit, right?
>> We do, but he should probably call and
speak to a team member.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Digestion and blood sugar. Okay.
Thank you, Charles.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you, Charles. Great
question. Now, pharmacist Ben, um, I
just want to remind everybody that if
you were referred to this program by
somebody specific, they are your person.
You need to get back to them. If you
found us on your own and you'd like to
speak with a certified holistic health
coach, you may do so by calling
8559493377.
Pharmacist Ben, final question.
>> Yes, ma'am. Carrie wants to know, is
there a standard lab test or a group of
tests that you recommend people to track
on their own? In California and other
states, individuals can purchase their
own lab tests.
>> The problem with lab tests, I I always
like going with symptoms rather than lab
tests because lab tests are based on on
reference ranges,
you know, high and low. And the
reference ranges themselves are
statistical algorithms. Nobody ever asks
where the the reference people say high
low, but nobody ever asked where the
reference range comes from. What's a
high compared to? What's a low compared
to? And there's these statistical
algorithms that are done and they do
they take like, you know, Caucasian and
black and Asian people and men and women
and young people. They love them all
together and they do whatever
statistical magic they do to try to come
up with these reference ranges. But
every individual is going to have their
own particular need. So you can't really
assume that you're high or low for you.
You can assume you're high or low for
the reference range, but whether it's
high or low for you specifically isn't
necessarily doesn't necessarily follow.
And that's the problem with statistics
for individuals. Statistics are for
large for large groups. This is the
problem with statistics. That's why Mark
Twain said there's three kinds of lies.
There's lies, there's damn lies, and
there's statistics. because statistics
mislead us into thinking that the that
it can be applied to individuals when
really they're designed to uh for large
groups and then we extrapolate it to try
to make it mean something for an
individual. And that's why you have
people who will say, "Oh, I got all the
symptoms of hypothyroidism, you know,
the dry skin, the hair falling out, the
nail problems." You go to the doctor, he
says, "Well, your thyroid is normal."
No, it's not normal. Obviously, you got
symptoms, but it's normal compared to
the reference range. So, I'm not a
really big believer in lab tests unless
they're super super extremely high or
low maybe. But I always go by your
symptoms. Trust your trust your symptoms
a and understand your symptoms, speak
your symptoms. A good health care
professional be able to not necessarily
individuals, but if you go to a good
health care professional, they should be
able to read your symptoms and form a
picture of what's happening in your body
from your symptoms.
>> And that's exactly what Dr. Wall teaches
and looks at.
>> Yes. Yes, because there's so many
different core health symptoms linked to
nutritional deficiencies to the tone of
900 poor health conditions since there's
90 essential nutrients and approximately
okay on average
10 um poor health conditions per
nutritional deficiency. So you multiply
that out which is simple math not
statistics. I come from a statistics
background and career. So
I do understand the statistics and
scrubbing data and I do not like doing
it. But 900 900 different poor health
symptoms folks related to nutritional
deficiencies. Chances are what you're
experiencing is a nutritional
deficiency.
So let's go to AJ with his hand up.
Well, I need to be able to see Ruth
Ellen just to make sure that this is
appropriate because, you know, sometimes
when when I do surprises on the show,
it's a little too loud for people's
ears. So, folks, if you if you're if you
have a ear sensitivity,
make sure you turn down your ear cuz
pharmacist Ben, I got something for you.
Are you ready?
>> Yes.
>> You sure?
>> All right. Well, I think I am. Don't fix
the fruit.
Don't fix
the root. DON'T FIX THE FRUIT. FIX THE
ROOT.
>> WOW. That
>> trash I didn't even like in high school.
AJ, you just
>> We got to work on that. AJ
>> wasn't good.
>> No, we got to work on that one. Oh man,
>> how about some like like some nice
gentle folk music?
>> We'll work on it.
>> Well, that's just like acoustic guitar,
you know, something something kind of
calm and quiet like like a bread or
David Gates, you know.
>> Okay.
>> You know what I'm talking about.
>> Well, I think so.
>> Yeah,
>> he has one. He has one. It's almost like
um
um the Grateful Dead kind of mellow.
>> Yeah. folky, mellow kind of.
>> He didn't like that one. He didn't.
>> Yeah, let's do that.
>> Okay.
>> And and one one final comment before we
go to the music part. Going back to
statistics, Carrie says, "As an engineer
turned natural path, she totally agrees
with us when it comes to those
statistics."
>> Who's now? Who is she? She's a
naturopath.
>> Jerry,
>> is she on the call?
>> She is on the phone. And what did you
say?
>> She didn't come on camera.
>> That's fine. What did she say she was
before she was a naturopath?
>> She's an engineer.
>> That's awesome because this is really
engineering. What we're talking about
here, the way you want to handle the
body is the way an engineer would
troubleshoot a problem. And and ask ask
what's her name? What's the name?
>> Carrie.
>> Ask Carrie if she agrees with that. This
is troubleshooting. This is engineering.
Really? Ask her if she agrees. Do
>> you agree? And
>> that's awesome that she's a naturopath,
too, because that's really how you solve
these problems. These are engineering
problems, really.
Right. Do you agree?
>> Absolutely.
>> Yes. Thank you. I'd love to meet Carrie.
I'd love to meet her.
>> Okay. We can make that happen.
>> Make that happen. Where is she from?
>> Um she's in California.
>> That's awesome. Yeah. I'd love to I'd
love to communicate with her. Facilitate
that. Is she new?
>> Uh no, she's been with longevity for a
while.
>> Oh, okay. I don't think I've met her.
All right. Well, I got to go. Thank you
so much.
>> All right. Okay. Thank you. Monday
night.
>> Monday night it is.
>> Bye everybody. Thank you.
>> All right. We've got pharmacist fin
bites with coach AJ Monday night
probably 900 p p.m. Eastern time. So
that's 8 central, 7 Mountain and 6
Pacific time if you are in the
US continent um on your time zones. So
thank you so much everybody for joining
us. So, I hope that you did get
something out of today's show as we had
lots of information, lots of different
symptoms coming from different,
what did you do, AJ?
Oh my goodness. He gives the boy
buttons. He's got to just push push
push.
Wow. Okay. So, if somebody could um
>> let me fix this.
>> Somebody could fix this. That would be
great.
>> Let me fix it. Let me fix it.
>> The host, please come on the screen. Um,
folks, I could not do this without my
team. Even when the team are pushing
buttons that they, you know,
accidentally, which I'm guilty myself,
push. Um, but hey, we're a family. We
forgive, we laugh, and we move on. If
that's something that you want to be
part of, make sure that you get back to
the person that shared this program with
you as we have a passion and a purpose
when it comes to helping others find a
better health journey and it's just a
fantastic place to be is on the solution
side of the issue and not creating more
problems. So again, get back with the
person that shared this program with
you. If there's no one to thank,
855-9493377.
This program is for educational purposes
only. It's not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician. But
please remember, you are an empowered
individual. Your body was designed
divinely by the creator. You are not
chemical deficient or pharmaceutical
deficient. And the poor health symptoms
that you are experiencing are more
likely like 99%
likely going back to statistics
that they are nutritional deficiencies.
There are some exceptions, but chances
are we're looking at nutritional
deficiencies and that's what this
program is all about is finding
solutions and providing solutions to
help you no longer be nutritional
deficient. So folks, thank you again. My
name is Becca Dukes. I am very honored
to be joined with joined here with my
team. That is Ruth Ellen Sanchez, my
executive production manager. Thank you
so much, Ruth Ellen. my
dear speedy fingers, Marilyn, who is
putting information into the chat as we
speak, making sure that you if you're
taking notes and you can't write as
fast, she can type even faster. So,
she's putting that into the chat for you
to help you with your note takingaking
that is only available here in the live
Zoom. So folks, if you want to join us
live Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, most
Wednesdays, Thursdays, and Fridays from
12 to 1 Pacific, 1 to 2 mountain, 2 to 3
central, 3 to 4 Eastern, and I think
it's like 9 to 10 or 10 to 11 in South
Africa as our next co-host, Albert, is
joining us from South Africa. Thank you
so much as he is our gatekeeper letting
people in from the waiting room into the
Zoom. Thank you, Albert. And we have Rod
out on the different platforms helping
to keep an eye on things and here in the
Zoom um and letting us know when there's
questions on the platforms that he is
watching. And we have
bringing in those questions as well as
she's keeping an eye on the different
platforms looking for questions as she
is a pioneer who I just love and ador.
She is one of my mentors in this whole
family. Thank you, Phyllis. And we have
AJ, my digital marketing director,
and he's helping us get on all the
different platforms and helping us with
technology
and making sure that we are able to
provide quality information in all
different medias to you. So folks, thank
you again for joining us. We'll see you
next time on Daily with Doc and Becca.
Bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Thank you.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Thank you.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
Thank you.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. We're honored to continue and
share the teachings of the founding
father of science of epigenetics, Dr.
Joel Wallik.
This program is for educational. ational
purposes only the content is not tend to
diagnose treat cure.